[Music]  yes  you've come to save us from this place  from this place you'll free us  the exposed brain quivers in expectation  please please before they return  they return  a newborn borneo from this husk  you realize you're talking to an  intellect devourer a minion of the mind  flayers who abducted you  remove us from this body from this case  free us  please  [Music]  you notice edema a swelling of the brain  causing pressure where it strains  against the shell of the skull  [Music]  the brain lifts from the skull but you  notice an  opportunity you could [ __ ] the  strange creature  making it more subservient should it  prove a threat  [Music]  creature seems unaware of your  interference  it relaxes in your hands  we are free our freedom is ours friend  the creature pauses listening  something behind your eyes seizes in  recognition  we must go to the home at the helm we  are needed  [Music]  [Music]  we are going to the home